not everybody is meant for greatness not
everybody has extreme talent in a
category that produces money but
everybody does have a talent that can
produce happiness as long as if you're a
great artist you know that you're not
gonna make 10 billion and as long as
you're making 10 billion that you know
that maybe you're not gonna be the most
noble or but you've got to just be true
you just have to know what your gonna be
about you just accept yourself and not
worry what everybody else thinks and go
all-in on you if you're not South by
Southwest come check it I'm heading to
the convention center about to get my
keynote 12:30 p.m. come see me
details in the text below
[Music]
in an hour one of the keynotes hurry
looking fresh bro
appreciate the new days I'm actually I
like your face thank you man I've got a
really good guy I got a really good guy
I put him on snapchat the other day I
was funny he was like what is this who
things better so cool or someone [ __ ]
up and they sent the bracelet
confirmation to everybody who RSVP'd yes
it's not everyone thinks they have only
a bracelet you live in the state of
Texas get your ass to book people
tonight 6 p.m. I will be there with a
live event really looking forward to it
what time is it
buta fine thank you guys I appreciate it
thanks for being here I'm gonna do a
quick survey of how many people know me
and don't know me based on that I will
speed up the process of what we're
really here to do which is straight up
QA in your [ __ ] mouth and so I want
to do some sort of weird contest um
right now I'm definitely not doing that
because I like to fight the system I
love you see ya
thank you
so what's the problem knotty needs more
support well [ __ ] be patient like how
old is he
you're [ __ ] young bro what are you
worried about it's not gonna happen
overnight nobody understands about
entrepreneurship and philanthropy
working together in Europe like you need
to you need to be patient
you used to grind something great
doesn't happen just because you did it
for a couple years or seven years or 13
years like you have to chip away chip
away chip away thank you you're welcome
can I can I get the mic guys can I get
the mic for one second about the book
signing can I get the mic for one second
[ __ ]
that would've been fun right yes I'll
see you at 6:00 brother
I'll see you thanks for all your help no
all right
I'm doing a book signing somewhere thank
you very early on my career he wanted me
to be like The Next Food Network Star so
I meet it was really cool this was
before the internet was real and like it
was a quote you know he said he was
really kind of not a great guy in my
opinion but he didn't say one thing that
has always stuck with me he said Gary
you never go on TV until the CDs in the
stores he talked about why his his
method was working people would promote
a week before the album was out and
there's no way to get at the next moment
at your height of emotion way too many
people in tech talk a big game before
their products if they think that hype
is gonna do them anything all that hype
is gonna do is clown them in the end
place soccer right up get the [ __ ] out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
love it
yeah
stay well awesome hope you enjoy the
book
Thank You heartache you're an
inspiration thank you
[Music]
let's top with some Latoya's crew this
dude right here is a rock stars me Gary
Vee get everybody else get off him get
out so fun
he comes to my boy guy guys thank you so
much for the Facebook live shoutout do
you rock throwing it up I like the way
guys playing the Facebook live guys
always got first mover advantage skills
he knows what's up on Facebook live guy
I want to talk to you about like the
size of this books I've been think about
doing some more micro kind of you know
like like we did here I think I need to
put out more versions of this I could
see a compliment to the askgaryvee
volumes in little thesis is like
askgaryvee around artists yeah so yeah
there's these are interesting to me a
man Brian you're genius Brian Grazer
great-great-great-great great guy
Frank I mean look at this Frank Gruber
one of my buddies my first South by hung
out with Frank who drank wine together
it's good to see your book here Frank
it's a lot oh now this this is the
section Reese Brady Rock love this guy
this book was a beast this was a big
selling book I like David a lot a
gentleman gentleman check him out real
good human real
all right Peter things just showing
everybody do autographs stickers I like
these autographs I could tear a coming
for one on you go to autograph Xerox an
autograph Xerox these are magic the
gathering on to the north cards you got
it I tend to be fast can I be like the
overboard I'm thrilled to do it back for
you this record possum in the muck [ __ ]
yes and it's it's a privilege to finally
document thank you better secret powers
lani secret powers Andy Rock
are you it's going on hard I got a help
on it
yo bonden why aren't you putting out
content on your snaps we're starting out
right now Gary
nine years hanging put your in splits
your snapchats good to see my look
drinking I own spanking yeah I'm playing
once a week once every ten days
how is we're talking about this Gary
yeah are all we're talking about is
going back to like 1997 permission-based
relationship Seth Godin sort of yeah you
look as Idol cell phone so we're talking
about a permission based marketing
direct marketing relationship I think I
think he I mean look I think I think it
depends on how you look at it I mean
what do I think new things happen not
that often I think I think everybody is
being [ __ ] with because the attention
is being staggered in so many different
directions and shifts very quickly if
you were all of our parents our moms and
dads if they were marketers a generation
ago they had it easy
we had a consistent platform of
marketing for a very long time the
internet that's the thing being
delivered in the phone by the way that
thing screwed it up it's tough now sorry
like ah do you think I'm happy that
Twitter's losing its attention I've 1.2
million followers on it I was at the top
of the heap I was winning I'm super
pissed I'm sad I'm not happy about it
but I'm not crying about it I'm learning
and executing and Instagram and snapchat
and that's just the way it is and it's
gonna move fast and what we have in and
again because bond is here in the
context of a lot of people room in a
corporate environment again the whole
thing is miss structured you have brand
managers these are business operators
these are people that think about profit
margin actually the formula of the
cookies they have to think about the
relationships with the retailers and on
top of all of that they have to
understand what's going on in marketing
and they and some random creative
director from widening kennedy get to
decide what the creative is that they're
gonna spend all their money on it's such
a [ __ ] up system it makes no common
sense in a 2016 world and there's a
reason so many people struggle to sell
[ __ ] because they don't know how that's
what I think it's average
catwalk great thank you
awesome snow up Kevin Pierce Kayla how
are you doing darling yeah get it really
thank you good for you thank you for
saying you're welcome that was good
panel right who do you want make it out
to inma
[Music]
and it's good
twenty-four/seven brother see it all on
the snapchat thank you brother
I wish you well Gary B get in hi Seth
I'm really right make sure she gets to
the right got it
[Applause]
thank you anything crazy right
this book is really good thank you
there's some books at hunts gallery come
and get them d-roc do something feel the
support I'm so sure I appreciate the
love every drop now Real Talk every time
[Music]
looking at the hard-on go hard on
snapchat or hard hard hard - every
eyeball you have to follow it it's gonna
really matter - everything you got into
this channel so where detentions gonna
be in 2019 be there are views but it's
something I think if we do it the right
way create something that is much more
sustainable
all right
but you're not gonna miss your kids
graduations all that you know that
they're more at the larmor in the Miss
checking's I have to tell people no on
Sundays regular about Thurs how about
Thursday night game there's eight up
until the schedule comes out we don't
book Thursday nights in the fall as well
because we literally are scared it's for
one decade it's so funny babe you're
like huh like is it religious I'm like
no yeah have you heard of the rare Jets
religious that's so fun to be here I
remember going down here for a party God
and it's unbelievable I just changed and
big nine years I've been coming here
[Music]
you'd be talking I'm really feeling that
this book has allowed me to be what I
really am you know it's funny I think
the first chapter speaks to what the
entire book is and ironically is the
first film Dirac ever made with me which
is clouds and dirt right this book if
you've read it or when you read it I
think you'll see has the crush it Thank
You economy kind of philosophies of what
the big issues at hand self-awareness
kind of the emotional e.q kind of heady
philosophical anthropology kind of stuff
going on but then it also has very
tactical like posts like this and use
this felt very tangible advice and so
it's been interesting for me to see
whether it's a Scoble or Guy Kawasaki or
other people saying well this is a
really how-to book like this is not a
fluff book this is really like thing the
things do these things like there's
things to be done and then other people
saying whoa Gary's fun let other people
writing reviews of that Gary's finally
grown up this really talks about the
bigger things and I think there's too
many people writing business books that
have never built a business they make
money on teaching people how to make
money when they've never made money in
any way besides teaching people how to
make money and I have a lot of cynicism
to that and I have a lot of cynicism to
the overall kind of place where
entrepreneurship is right now and I'm
excited to this book and this momentum
and this week and in general feeling
you're catching me at a super
interesting time I'm super emotional
about
clearly in my stomach feeling that I've
taken another step step in the journey
that I think is inevitable and and I'm
excited about it and so your turnout
tonight means a lot to me and so I thank
you very very very much you know the
ironic thing that people don't know
about me is if there was 50,000 people
here or if there was one person here I'd
[ __ ] bring it you know I think when
you're in the business of marketing
something that you don't actually do
it's all about listening and asking
questions right so the first thing I
would do is really try to understand
what I'm trying to accomplish so if you
ask me what I think I am I think I'm a
counter-puncher it's why I did Jab Jab
Jab right hook I think in nature I'm a
counter puncher right I'm trying to
understand all of you and then I
reverse-engineer it and then I started
stacking what I want to do based on what
I know you want you know why a lot of
you were here
because of all the other business
coaches and all this they're full of
[ __ ] they're trying to hold their best
stuff so that you feel like they're
giving you a little bit and they want to
suck you into their [ __ ] mastermind
and their [ __ ] ebooks and [ __ ] like
that I'm giving my [ __ ] away for free
every three years I come in I'm like can
you buy a $20 buck and then I love one
of my fans I'm like you know some of you
and you guys see this the comments like
Gary alright enough of the book I'm like
really really like I can't throw that
little right hook once every three years
for 90 days I'm sorry I'm a real [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know meanwhile these are the
same people one guy really pissed me off
and then I went looked at everything
he's doing same dude that bought
somebody's $300 ebook on snapchat where
the guy's stole all my content and
repackaged it for $325 business before I
came out and started being a pun dn't
like I David I know you like like I love
it like when I started my agency like I
built an agency since I've been running
it for four years from three to a
hundred million dollars in revenue on
Madison Avenue right like that's real
think about this I already had money
when I started vaynermedia and because I
was running a business that I was
treating it like a business
we started out of buddy media's
conference room so I didn't have to pay
rent like entrepreneurs these days are
raising money getting all nice fancy and
they said they're just trying to raise
money for the next round they don't have
a business so I like the way you reacted
for the newsletter don't worry about how
I'm doing or anybody else
everything works by the way not
everything works for you got it you're
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you